all right everybody welcome back to the
patreon post
show you know we try to get through this
material all in about an hour's time
sometimes it's like so much material we
can't fit it and pack it all
in so we get an opportunity to give you
guys a
little perk that's different than
everybody else and uh
so we're gonna just pick up this
conversation basically where we kind of
left off yesterday
because i think there's a few other
clips that that i really want to show to
kind of seal this case in
that there are a lot of people actors
specifically
that really invite spirits to come in
and help them act
or the methods that they're using
is really opening themselves up to to
this kind of demonic
possession find out on this episode of
led live
light exposing darkness so i think we
left off with the word
entertainment here and i just wanted to
quickly give you guys a little bit of
it's interesting when you do an
etymology of the word entertainment
it's made up of three words and the
words are enter which means
obviously to come in and the word tane
is from a latin word and it means to
like literally grasp hold
possess occupy or control
meant literally means to keep in that
state or to hold into that state so
just the word entertainment means
literally to come in
possess you and hold you in that state
of possession
which is very interesting to me yeah
that you know the devil's not shy about
calling it what it is
he's got a channel for everybody you
know and he's channeling his thoughts
into our minds and of course uh on the
on the last show we talked about
hollywood which is you know used in
the occult world as a witch's wand to
basically put people to sleep so
you know the devil's not shy to call it
exactly what it is and
you know we sometimes in christianity we
go nah i can't be
like that you know they even call them
american idols
and they're celebrities we celebrate
them
i think there's enough literal um
terminology that that we should know
better than to
involve ourselves with a lot of this
kind of stuff but um
i wanted to share with you uh i don't
know if we talked about toy story did we
talk about toy story on the last one
so uh when toy story 2 came out you guys
remember the little dog slinky
yeah he he actually was voiced by
an actor named jim varney um you
probably
maybe recognize that name from earnest
yeah ernest goes to camp
or he was kind of a funny funny actor
but uh he actually died of lung cancer
at age 50 years old
and when he died obviously toy story
being such a large
movie they wanted to replace him and
they they searched for
years to actually find an actor that
could portray
this slinky character in the same manner
that jim barney did
and they ended up landing on an
acquaintance of jim barney's
and he was actually able to channel
his late dead friend and that's where he
came up with this voice
even for a voice just the voice so this
is this is actually coming from
entertainment weekly okay so this is not
some obscure
uh article or whatever right here and it
says in here in the article
jim barney who died of 50 years old um
you know
after the release of toy story 2. then
they found this guy clark
and clark says i went in and i say i
invoked and channeled varney's spirit
just to get his voice so you know it's
just
it's just fascinating to me that that
you know the spirit world
is interested in entertainment right
that's fascinating to me we talked a
little bit about the dark knight
you guys remember um uh heath ledger
when he portrayed the dark knight
was a very very creepy performance um in
fact
he to prepare for that role he locked
himself in a hotel room for
four months four months that's crazy and
he literally
only slept for two hours a night okay if
you if you don't sleep
you will literally go insane after a
short amount of time but he locked
himself in this
in this hotel room and he had a journal
in fact you can you can look up the
journal i didn't have time to show it
here
but you can just go on the internet and
look up the journal and it was full of
disturbing images
and so what he would do is he would sit
there and focus on these really
disgusting
things think about the worst thoughts
you could possibly think about
and when he came out he is known
heath ledger's known as a method actor
where he never breaks the role
so it's like they can let the character
inhabit them
so much that even when the cameras are
not rolling
they are literally not heath ledger they
are the joker
for that entire time that they film but
he didn't have a lot of friends during
that time period
everybody on set i read all these
articles everybody on set said that they
were so creeped out
when he would show up on set you could
just feel this
presence that was unworldly and who was
the
the villain in black panther do you
remember something jordan
yeah the guy uh-huh yeah he michael b
jordan yes yes
he was in an interview saying that he
had to go to therapy for months after
manning that road so it was no real plan
i didn't have a
i didn't have an escape plan either so
like every day was just
going into this place and i just tried
to stay there as long as i could
and then when it was all over i think
i think just being in that kind of uh
that mind state that that that real
unapologetic you know
just just real like you know whatever
all the time
kind of kept it caught up with me and
like i got a little you know a little
depressed it was tough for me for a
minute you know
just readjusting to being around the
people that care about me
getting that love that i shut out for a
long time
like i shut out love i didn't want love
and affection you know i wanted to be in
this lonely place
as long as i could in order to kind of
capture the essence of what eric
you know stevens was what killmonger was
so when we wrap the film
you know i'm like in my mind it's like
okay cool go back to you know regular
life get back to l.a and be cool but
it was a little tough for me at first to
kind of like expect it's hard just to
lay him down
yeah and be done with it yeah how did it
take you a while it took me
it took me you know i mean i don't
really know exactly when i came out of
it but you know i
went to therapy you know what i'm saying
i started talking to people started
unpacking a little bit
and i in in you know like everything
that's so
interesting i find that so interesting
because i think the body doesn't know
the difference i remember
um having this conversation with a
famous actor once about
uh anthony hopkins i was saying anthony
hopkins i feel for you because
you know all the stuff you're taking in
you do so well and he said
i used to not think about it but as i've
gotten older i do think about it because
he was
saying that he had just done a film and
he had said to the director he was going
to do one wide shot and one close-up
because he had to have a heart attack
because he didn't want to put his body
in that state
too many times because your body doesn't
know the difference when you get
yourself into that state and so
that's why i think it's interesting for
people to hear that
even though you're playing this
character sometimes the essence of that
the
energy of that still remains 1 000 still
remains
many actors have done this in fact they
actually bring a psychologist on the set
in case they break down
completely on set you know these people
are putting themselves through eye
opening
so i want you to listen to this
interview of this guy who played mr
twoface
the actor and he was in only one scene
with heath ledger they actually even
though he's in the whole movie
they only had one scene together and it
was in a hospital scene so he's
describing
what it was like to work with heath
ledger when he came in the room listen
to this
my one experience with heath on the film
was
our scene together in the hospital bed
which is really my only scene with him
and
it was um i was in the hospital bed that
day and i thought well i don't really
have any lines
what am i gonna do and i had no idea
what was gonna happen and so i was
got in the bed and they were lighting
and chris was walking around and doing
things and then he
came around and heath was always in
character so he would come around and
you know be talking to himself in the
corner
like this and then he would come up i
was laying there and i was watching him
the whole time
and he came up and would walk around me
like this
and i would watch him and i'd watch him
he'd walk around the hospital bed like
this i'd watch him didn't say anything
for maybe an hour
he would walk around and then we'd watch
him and then he'd start saying his lines
and i would watch and boom watch him
come around to bed like this
and then all of a sudden my hand would
go up like this and he
caught my hand so we just went through
this organic process of developing this
scene which was really nothing
and then when we came time to shoot we
had this thing beautifully choreographed
and
you know he did we never said a word to
each other wow
yeah and then it was a long day and we
walked out
um to our back to our trailers and heath
was here and i was walking and he puts
his hand on my shoulder and he goes
that's what acting's all about
that interesting so you know he's
walking around like
stuck in this character and um there was
actually a lot of people on that set
that that
that really were super disturbed by it
and
talked about you know his just portrayal
of this character
and but this is praised like this is art
this is something people respect
someone literally going insane in front
of you and you're like wow that's
amazing he won an oscar for best
supporting actress for the for an actor
for that role
now uh matthew mcconaughey went on jay
leno and he was also talking about being
a a method actor and some of the other
actors that he was working with jay was
kind of saying you know like
they're method actors do you have a
particular method and listen to his
method
you have a process you do before scenes
and you've been doing this a long time
what are you talking about
yeah i think so yeah to relax yeah
explain what daddy
it's uh sort of a little meditational
chant that i'll get going if it's early
in the morning it's cold and i've got to
get the day started get my voice
loosened up
so that's right i'm in mind yeah
yeah i just get a little i get a little
rhythm whatever it is
yeah there you go whatever you got
whatever and it's different rhythm for
every
every uh character and every role so
he does this sort of like meditation
and does this mantra says the same thing
over and over and over again
and ritual yeah and remember when we had
um
leah on what did she say got her into
meditation
like literally or got her into that
space of of being able to communicate
with the spirits was literally
meditation yeah meditation right so
these method actors often to get into
these roles
they sit there and they meditate and
they meditate and they meditate
you guys remember shirley temple do you
know do you know what she was actually
really known for as a young actress like
why everybody was enamored with her
performances
do you know kind of like the history of
her acting
she was able to cry on command which is
very difficult for a young child
to do and they would literally go can
you can you cry
and she would go over to a corner with
her mother
and meditate and empty her mind and then
she could immediately cry
wow so you know this this is something
that
that is i think borderline whether you
call it method acting or whatever
they're opening themselves
up to the spirit world i was kind of
shocked by this because i want to bring
it
like full circle back to us today this
isn't just
acting that that we notice this kind of
stuff in
media i mean uh you know here's uh oprah
winfrey right
she's had a lot of supernatural
spiritualism type
content over the years um but she
literally invited somebody onto her show
and then called the demon out wanted her
to channel it
on the show this is on national
television watch this channel my food
okay in order for me to do this i just
need a couple of moments
she said i want you to channel my food
so she's meditating a couple of moments
are deadly on television
the silence could kill you you know but
you're gonna allow it
i was gonna say hummus song oprah
well i i i don't wanna interfere with uh
the process whatever
so creepy
he's not buying it i take this this this
to me that this is my fool
adjusting to what reach my level
vibrational level
tell me my food why why or why first of
all who are you
my beloved woman bless you i am honored
to be in what is called your presence
ask you that which be i i be that which
you are
entity all things if you watch this
it's like either this person is
seriously insane
or like i've seen so many videos of this
yeah it's always with that rolling the
r's
loved by that which is called the father
that is within you and within all things
this is nonsense
that's bi thank you
indeed um
anyway it goes it goes on and on but
what do you think about that
on national television i think they know
exactly what they're doing first they're
making it kind of like a joke
right to kind of like be numbing people
like oh if you see this it's actually a
joke it's not like something real that
you should be um you know intimidated by
a fair or
like a red flag should come up right did
you see how like she transitioned
like how her head went down it's like
it's almost like she went to sleep
there was an actress in a 1981 movie
called possession
if you've ever seen it but there's a
real famous scene with this actress
um who played someone that was possessed
and she's like in the subway
and the way that she's like contorting
and like moving around i mean dude
chills just go up on my spine when i
when i notice that
and the actress had to have months if
not years of therapy
after that and she said she will never
ever portray a role like that again
because it almost took her like
just took her over and so when you're
watching this real demonic possession
it's real i mean this is not like play
yeah i want to know what skeptics how
they logic this like why would somebody
need
months or years of therapy for playing a
part if people are
they're trying to justify like it's just
acting it's nothing you know
and the part took an hour to shoot you
know what i mean so why would you need
years of therapy to literally portray
something for an hour
and they'll just say well that person
just sounds mentally unstable well a lot
of actors must be because they're all
having to go through that right
so i screenshotted this just to show you
this is this is coming from oprah's
youtube
this is her official channel this is not
just someone who you know posted
something she was posting and she's not
hiding it because she's putting it back
on you
proud of it that's why when you read the
bible
in ecclesiastes nine verse five it says
for the living know that they will die
but the dead know
nothing yes if you are channeling
something if some
spirit is speaking through you or saying
that they were
some departed loved one or whatever that
is
not your loved one that is a
demonic entity that is that is speaking
through you and she continued on with
this interview right so she's like yeah
the whole thing you're directly
communicating with this demon
exactly you're watching the the bible
has clear counsel
to not approach do not talk do not
that's right oh my goodness that is
crazy so i wanted to show you steve
harvey
recently invited on um someone who could
channel spirits
this is a professed christian someone
who has a morning show giving devotions
this is alarming to me yeah he's always
talking about god
well you hear a lot of people say god
but i never heard that he had a
devotional
show i would in high school i would turn
on the radio and listen to him before i
went to school
he would pull open the bible and have
this whole devotional segment
yeah like this encouraging piece so what
i find is really interesting and the
reason why i wanted to show
this particular clip to you guys is
because look at the manner in which
these so-called spirits are speaking
through this medium
and look at what kind of people it
targets listen to this
all right before the break uh teresa uh
started to read our audience
but uh spirit is still communicating
with her
theresa go for it can you please stand
back from this drink
man i need some lick onions scotch
channeling you would need more than one
scotch
so just yeah what happens is
what i asked to be done was to bring
forward other souls
but more importantly your son says mom
you wouldn't have known that i was going
to depart
no do you understand that no yeah he
says
nobody knew no oh he also shows me his
sweatshirt so do you have his sweatshirt
or his jacket that you wear
okay so know that when you wear that
know that his soul is with you did you
make a blanket or quilt out of his
clothing
i'm starting to yeah perfect it means
that he supports all of the choices and
decisions
so if you don't think that he's at peace
there's no way that i would know that
he says oh he also talks about his
headstone
yes he says it's very different he shows
me this big black headstone i can see my
reflection in it
and it's very unique because you have
like either something is picture
engraved
and then some type of saying on there
just come sit with me a while and take a
break
and it says 219 for our area code and
it's got a burst of a harry chavin song
that was kind of like a
perfect like to validate that every
choice and decision that you ever made
with your son
alive and also departed he says i want
to thank you
for giving me that gift he says and i
want you mom
to know that i live life through your
eyes so i want you to be happy
so now every time you smile my soul is
smiling in heaven
your daughter shows me the butterflies
ma'am so do you connect with the
butterflies
perfect so know that when you see the
butterflies you know that it's the
butterfly
did you do something with your
daughter's hand print after she died on
a sheet or something where you did a
family hand print
when my daughter passed away the nurse
at the hospital
printed my daughter's hand and her
footprint on a
summons at heart perfect so you know
to validate that it was her soul's time
to leave
let me ask you this was there a point
where she got better
before she passed away okay because she
i said to her i go what do you why did
what do you show me like doing all these
great things
and she keeps talking about disney and
all this stuff and i said i go
what is that she goes theresa she goes i
am so thankful
that i was blessed with another brief
time here of not being sick
she says because i was able to do so
many things with my family she says and
i would have traded that for anything
she goes but then i went so quickly
after that really fast
she says mom i want you to focus on that
time that extra time i was given back
and i wouldn't have traded that for
anything
and she tells me you smell her i do
so know that when you know that she's
with you at that exact moment you also
have things in your car in memory of her
does it fall and move like when you're
driving yes that's her
i said to her you better be careful your
mom is going to crash your car
are you all right oh this is crazy right
here see see see i sit here
you you you see see it's crazy to me you
got to go get this book
i'm man i'm scared hold my hand's just
wet you ain't gonna stick
you understand look at my hand anyway
you you get you get the point satan is
so what are they targeting them dude
they're they're going after like they're
targeting people's ignorance
yeah they're they're going after
christians who believe that their loved
ones are in heaven and she's giving them
a message
and these all these emotions are taken
over
they're pulling on heart strings you
know problem is people don't know what
the bible says
about what happens when you die that's
the fundamental problem
it's the same problem people had in the
mid-1800s because
right around that time you had a lot of
spiritualistic activity
especially in new york there's a lot of
movements that started in in
within 20 miles of each other and
when you look at the end of the 1800s
one-third of americans would say
they identify as a spiritualist and you
think well how can that be this is a
christian
nation you know we have all these
christian values the problem is they
didn't dissociate the two
yeah so they said no no it's it's it's
all together right they had lost
that truth about what the bible says and
so they're completely fine communicating
with spirits yeah this
is saying they're in heaven you know
yeah and and if
they're being told things that only the
family would know
or something that's going on then all
yeah all of a sudden it's going to be
like yeah i totally believe what
everything you say and it's real easy to
kick you off of kilter
speaking of entertainment dan aykroyd
his family's history with spiritualism
goes back a long way back to the 1800s
and for their entertainment he talked
about his i think it's his grandfather
they would have a medium that would they
would sit around the table at night and
that was their entertainment is the
community to see what the medium has to
say
and i would tell them all kinds of stuff
like you know there's going to be an
earthquake and tell them
you know about it and like when it was
going to be and where it was going to be
funny thing is it was always right about
the event never write
about the timing but really just
interesting their entertainment you know
that's
yeah so here's the thing how do we tell
the difference i know there's
verses like first john four and and
verses in ephesians because it's not
only demons that can tell you things
about yourself that you haven't shared
also angels can i remember we had eric
wilson on the show and he was talking
about
that practice of looking at the eye and
seeing which part of your body which
organ of your body is
um having some issues and he said that's
not real
like medical science like that's just a
demon telling them
and i went to someone like that who is a
professed christian i know this person
like we study the bible together spirit
prophecy all these things
so um as far as i know she's not
willingly or knowingly communicating
with demons or opening herself up to
that
and she told me things about myself like
i said that she told me that i sleep
slept on my left side how in the world
would she know that so i was like wow
okay i guess there's something to this
because you're telling me something
personal
you're looking into my eye and you're
telling me what i should improve
he said no that's complete like demonic
influence so
the question is like how how even the
very if if it's possible even the very
elect
elect will be deceived that's right how
could i have known that this is not okay
unless eric wilson said something that's
right that's right i think you know in
some situations god does wink at our
ignorance but i i also believe that
that you know as best as possible
we should make ourselves aware of these
tactics and these tools because if you
have no idea what they
are yeah then it's easy to fall into it
and right now
we don't live in a in a day and age
where
information is hard to come by we live
in a danger where it's very easy to come
by
so you know i think real quick you could
do some digging on the internet
ask questions yeah and ask questions and
get to the bottom of that if i really go
to this person they're telling me things
that
only i know what's wrong with this be
inquisitive about that don't just
take that in you know spiritualism
defined by the by the dictionary is a
system of belief religious practice that
communicates through the dead especially
through mediums right
now i'm going to give you guys a little
sneak peek because keith
is working on a documentary called
channels
you guys will want to hear this like
documentary towards the end of the year
i hope that we can get this thing done
but um it really goes over the the
boom of technology in the late 1800s and
how spiritualism really was
was feeding a lot of the things back
then
but then we see that same thing in the
boom of technology of today we see the
spiritualism ramping up once again
and so the reason i wanted to bring this
up what is spiritualism what is a medium
and and what is that communication when
the devil used the snake in the garden
of eden
he was using a medium and uh you know
that's when he literally said uh you
know you're not going to die if you eat
this piece of fruit but god said
if you eat this fruit you shall die so
the purpose of spiritualism
is literally to change what god said
that's it
that all spiritualism is the only only
servicing function of it is to literally
do something different than what god
said
that's it and so what i see in hollywood
is these guys are using spiritualism and
and and channeling different spirits and
stuff literally what they're going to be
doing is showing you either a way of
life that's different than what god
wants
or they're going to talk about you know
like like anything that
that you need to do away with the bible
like what leo was talking about
the the other day and uh you know you
need to enlighten yourself with this
right
medium of course you look that up in the
dictionary and it just means
um you know a way to to communicate
using something um at the very bottom uh
it's interesting in the dictionary it
uses
uh the word communication information
entertainment newspapers television as a
medium
yeah right and the plural form of medium
is media
and this is once again where the devil
is literally calling it what it is
yeah and it just goes over the top it's
going to change the
channel exactly of our our minds so
that's where i think
you know we've used this verse probably
in everything that we've actually
produced uh to the law and to the
testimony if it speaks not according to
this word it is because
there is no light in them so
if you balance everything against that
there is a day
that honestly will be very confusing
we know this that that something is
brewing in the in the
in the world stage right now there is
whether you
whether you know prophecy or or whether
you can see that our world is coming
apart
satan is preparing for his final trick
his final umph to try to take away
the believers of god out of god's fold
that's that's what the bible tells us
and the only way that we're going to be
able to navigate through this
is through standing on the word of god
amen
witchcraft on the rise lukewarm
christianity on the rise
new age blending of christianity on
their eyes i mean he's
he's preparing the people to accept this
second thessalonians
2 9-11 says the coming of the lawless
one is in accordance to satan with all
power
signs lying wonders and all unrighteous
deceptions for those who perish because
they did not receive a love of the truth
the bible says the ones that will
fall prey to a lot of these devices are
people that didn't train themselves
to be in love with the truth and so
another
just side note why it's important to not
just soak in all these
you know modern movies and things like
this is man there's demonic spirits that
are working behind the stages
revelation 3 10 says because thou has
kept the word of my patience i will also
keep thee from the hour of temptation
so if we stand on the word of god god
will keep us
from that hour of temptation
you just want to say i was just going to
springboard off of that it's a more
biblical
um council that runs light right along
with second thessalonians and
revelation 13. it says in deuteronomy 13
if there rise among you a prophet or a
dreamer of dreams
and gives you a sign or a wonder and the
signer wonder comes to pass wherever he
spoke to you saying
let us go after other gods which thou
has not known and let us serve them
you shall not hearken to the words of
that prophet or that dreamer of dreams
for the lord your god proves you to know
whether you love the lord your god with
all your heart
and with all your soul you shall walk
after the lord your god and fear him and
keep his commandments
and obey his voice and you shall serve
him and cleave unto him
and that prophet or that dreamer of
dream shall be put to death
because he has spoken to turn you away
from the lord your god which brought you
out of the land of egypt
and redeemed you out of the house the
house of bondage to thrust you out of
the way which the lord your god
commanded you to walk in
so shall you put the evil away from the
midst of you
so this very very powerful text saying
you know just because
you get you know whether it's a prophet
or a dreamer of dreams and i think this
has a
bit of an application to you know
broaden that a little bit and talk about
people who are mediums or channels or
whatever if they're giving you
information and it doesn't line up with
the word of god well first of all
it already doesn't wind up with the word
of god because they're
communicating with you know other
uh things that are not godly
and that automatically acts as it right
there the bible says so it doesn't even
matter if what they say comes to pass
it doesn't matter if it's true the bible
says don't have anything to do with it
and we may not have to you know kill
them we shouldn't kill them but we can
act as if they were put away like
just yeah they should be dead to us yeah
so i gotta end on this note okay how
many of you saw
the grinch that stole christmas by jim
carrey
you saw it you saw it you saw it you did
not see it okay so
jim carrey is reflecting on playing this
role and he's another method actor that
completely becomes consumed by the other
one
but listen to how the language he talks
about
in this character taking him over and
basically said nope
i'm gonna do the movie you sit down
check this out
so jim yes what does christmas
mean to you
every movie i've gotten in my life i
could tell you how that
was the absolute manifestation of my
consciousness at that time
i'm the grinch that stole christmas
[Music]
when i heard i had the part please
welcome jim carrey
it's as if i went into a fugue state
being the virgin
and hyde showed up that story is just
such a part of christmas so yeah it was
incredibly important not to screw it up
what happened after was out of my
control
it was not me i was not making choices
based on what jim does
here's your motivation he felt it was
necessary
for him to stay in the character
whatever just
keep it kind of loosey at some point he
tapped me on the shoulder
and said sit down i'll be doing my movie
the attitude was already there when you
put that makeup on there's no choice
that
knows the jowls
universal they didn't want the footage
we took behind the scenes to surface so
that people wouldn't think i was an
you're gonna have people that are gonna
sue this production for mental stress
yeah there's feelings of guilt feelings
like
damn i lost control again
to him it was absurd
it was completely absurd and some of it
becomes a little bit real
when the movie was over i couldn't
remember who i was anymore i'm the
grinch
i'm the grinch so you step through the
door not knowing what's on the other
side
what's on the other side is everything
[Music]
i know him as well as i can know him but
uh who do you know
even when they're right in front of you
dude that's scary man
isn't scared who do you know even though
they're right in front of you it's
fascinating because it's like in putting
that on it's like he's wearing a mask
and he did another movie called the mask
right you put the mask on and become
somebody different
yeah you could never watch the movie the
same way again knowing this
no i believe that these guys are
literally
modern day possession allowing
themselves to be taken over
like he said i didn't even know who i
was when i came back that's what i was
just thinking about
and you see so many interviews of him
like he literally lost
who he was he he appeared to go insane
because he's just
allowed himself to be taken over so
shattered in so many different ways like
multiple personalities which one's me
yeah so what does that mean for us
christians today
watching these movies knowing this is
the method that these actors are using
and they're portraying demonic entities
on screen
it's powerful it's like being
entertained by demons it's powerful
we hope you guys got a little blessing
out of this we don't mean to totally
leave you scared
there is a remedy for that and i believe
the remedy is jesus
you know pray prayerfully think about
these things um
you know and think about the topic of
entertainment whether you want to let
this
stuff into your life um these are some
of the things that we are barely
scratching the surface of what's
underneath
there um but i really believe that uh
you know movies are powerful they get in
your brain they tinker around
and they put thoughts and seeds of ways
of thinking inside of our minds so
be careful with that and uh as always
man thank you so much for
for supporting our ministry pray for us
and uh we'll hope to catch you guys on
the next episode
[Music]
you